speaking of lonely I was just watching
television by myself speaking to it as
if it was another live human being and I
saw this commercial for this this this
new website called farmersonly.com this
is not a commercial people this is
actually an observation it was basically
showing uh you know some couple of
ranchers a couple of farm girls and they
just walk in the fields by themselves
you know playing with their face finger
playing with each other you know you do
that when you were a little kid you'd do
that little thing where you put your
thumb and index finger together on both
hands he didn't kind of do the little
almost like there's an invisible tiny
screw you know there's some poor woman
walking through like these uh a bunch of
corn you know and the cows are all
concerned to the point they're actually
speaking English to one at one another
you know about each of them going how
the hell they're gonna meet each other
and then all of a sudden this Whelan
[ __ ] comes over the top and just starts
singing you'll never be lonely at
farmersonly.com so it's basically their
Facebook and you should go and look at
it on YouTube that's what you should do
you shouldn't work you know where do you
work what are you doing is it your dream
or somebody else's you're just a cog in
the wheel you know are they really gonna
notice if you stop working everybody
else is working why don't you just
[ __ ] you know Tour de France just
sort of draft behind a couple people's
today you know take a [ __ ] Monday off
so anyways check out this video and you
know what's the funniest thing about it
is the comments underneath it as the
amount of people who [ __ ] on you know
just immediately thinking how dumb
people are it's like these people grow
our [ __ ] food do you understand that
I'm sure they don't know where the rave
is you know well who the most popular
bands are or how to get from [ __ ]
Brooklyn over to Staten Island oh right
they don't how to do that [ __ ] they
don't know how to put on a [ __ ] shiny
shirt right go jump on the subway and go
down to Wall Street and make sure old
people eat dog food for the rest of
their [ __ ] lives yeah they don't how
to do that you know what they not to do
that I make then I make or
right for planet so it grows they don't
make it God makes it and he makes that
fertile [ __ ] country you know it's
got to be really hard to catch herpes
out there you don't mean I mean it much
spread really [ __ ] slowly Jesus
Christ I mean you even well you must
[ __ ] rub them at least two loads out
by the time you get to our house just
sitting there driving and driving
[ __ ] tornado man you pull over rub
another one out and by then you know
what the [ __ ] I'm going over there for
anyways [ __ ] I got more teeth in her
that's a deal-breaker look now I'm
making fun of them at farmersonly.com
that's gonna be embarrassing you and
your [ __ ] neighbour are gonna join
you be the only ones on the site yeah I
thought you wanted to [ __ ] me it just
was too long a walk you know what I'm
saying just bless it's tornado season
you never know what's gonna happen I
like how that they're called the flyover
States and no reason to go there
yeah no reason to check in on the food
supply uh like you're gonna that'd be a
good thing to [ __ ] freak him out with
just show up with like a clipboard [ __ ]
you doin city boy well they actually you
know something they make themselves kind
of separatist because at the end of is
that even a word they actually say this
city folks don't understand what don't
we understand lowliness say what it is
come to New York and be alone with
everybody you never heard that you
[ __ ] you know what [ __ ] them goddamn
farmers Jesus Christ what you don't have
your cousin's phone number so are you
sick of [ __ ] your sister so now you
got to get your own Facebook and see the
jokes are just too easy here people you
know take a [ __ ] a pig